the bamako residents of president
ibrahim bubakar
keita secure and heavily guarded but
instead of keeping people
out these soldiers were keeping him in
he and prime minister bubu sese were
detained here on tuesday
confusion prevailed all day with no
explanation by the military or
government
until president cater appeared on state
television announcing his resignation
i want no blood to be spilled to keep me
in power and that's why i would like to
thank
the million people for their warmth i am
telling you now that i'm resigning from
my position as the president
and all my other positions and i
announce the dissolution of the assembly
and the government west african bloc
ekawas
responded forcefully to the coup
isolating mali through border closures
suspending financial flows and called
for sanctions against
coup organizers and their supporters but
many malians
welcomed the coup as word spread of a
mutiny
crowds frustrated with the president and
his government spurred the soldiers on
some ransacked and burned government
officers
we have come out today to call for the
total resignation of president cater
because we heard there were shots fired
by the military and we've come out to
help our soldiers get rid of the
president
we are tired the country is paralyzed
and i do not want this government
the soldiers began their mutiny at a
base on the outskirts of bamako
the same base that saw a 2012 army
uprising that opened the way to caita's
presidency
heavily armed troops were later seen
escorting a vehicle
believed to be carrying the president
we're very happy because this is a
liberation for the people of mali
all of mali's people were waiting for
this day all of mali's people were
waiting for the president and his men to
allow us to breathe
president cater has faced weeks of
opposition protests calling for his
departure
after disputed parliamentary elections
earlier this year
swathes of the country are already
outside the control of the government
that struggled to contain
an armed insurgency that's claimed
thousands of lives
now the military has forced president
cater to step down
it's unclear what their plan is for mali
and
its leadership charlotte bellas al
jazeera
the coup has sparked widespread
international condemnation the african
union has emphatically condemned the
arrests
the european union says it's rejecting
all unconstitutional change in the
country and is calling for dialogue
the office of the french president
emmanuel macron was quick to react
and his urging soldiers to return to
barracks the u.n security council is to
hold an emergency meeting on wednesday
let's join william lawrence an expert on
north africa and a professor of
political science at the american
university in washington dc good to have
with us again on the program sir the
situation very fluid and one wonders
what the fate of the president
might be under the guard of disgruntled
soldiers
well this was very um confusing today
because it started it would seem to be
as a
mutiny against uh lack of pay to the
military
and the next thing we knew the military
had not only taken over that base but
they descended obamacare
arrested the president prime minister
around 4 30 p.m and then proceeded to
arrest a bunch of other officials
including those that would be involved
in the constitutional succession
i took a look at the malian constitution
this evening to be sure and there's
really
no one to succeed there's been no
military announcement just
in terms of who's in charge or what they
want so some mali and commentators have
been saying
we have no president we have no
parliament we have nothing it is
very strange situation military coups of
course are no stranger to mali
but kieta was able to quell discontent
amongst the military
when he first came to power in 2013 and
sort of unify
generally a fractured economy and a
society that
needed guidance what went wrong
well he his uh tenure grew out of the
last coup with the same military base in
2012
and so in many ways he was the
replacement power that was supposed to
fix molly's problems
but they have three overlapping sets of
problems
there's a severe political crisis that
grew out of the botched
march 2020 elections this is severe
economic
crisis uh complicated by covet 19
and there's a severe security uh crisis
which has led to the arrest
of one of the major opposition leaders
held by terrorists in the north
and uh lots of grievances
both about the failure to contain
terrorism but also
the actions of the military against
civilians to uh you know overreactions
to
uh in terms of terrorism and so there's
a lot of discontent
and like so many uh similar protests
like in algeria or sudan where
the protests came together with the
consensus of what was wrong
and brought down a president what we'll
quickly see is that there's not very
much consensus about what to do next
and who should represent uh most malians
even the
the best known leader of the opposition
deco is a controversial figure among
many malians so uh there's the leader
there's a lack of leadership at the top
right now and of course while that
confusion remains i mean let's just
focus in
on the insurgents uh insurgency in the
north
of the country uh primarily tackling
armed groups like al qaeda and isil
how much of a problem has this been for
the president he really hasn't
been able to get a handle on it
absolutely um it's a problem that's
gotten steadily worse over the last four
or five years
with uh by some estimates uh
four or five or tenfold increase in
in deaths caused by terrorism the
problem from mali has bled into burkina
and niger next door and it's become a
regional issue uh which has to do with
these border closures and other
condemnations that are going on and
there's both dissatisfaction among those
that want terrorism to get harder
and those who want to make peace uh with
with certain terrorist groups like the
deco the leader who i mentioned who
wants dialogue with the jihadists up
north
and so there's a real frustration with
this
worsening problem leading to more
violence which is also missing with
mixing with ethnic violence but no
consensus on how to best handle it
whether it needs a harder approach or a
softer approach
william lawrence it's always good to get
your insight thanks very much for
joining us
from washington dc thank you